today
a lot of things have happened today okay
one amy
coney barrett they voted for 12
democrats didn't show up so
12 10 if you want to put it there 12-0
for them not showing up to george floyd
you heard about uh shoving you know the
whole thing they didn't think that the
third degree murder could could
could stick yeah so that's the second
thing that happened today which again
more frustration thing third uh the
sasha cohen borat ii clip came out with
rudy giuliani
in the interview he got spooked and
which is hilarious i know you've been
following the story
i mean that in itself i was thinking
when it came to october surprises
could floret's timing have been any
better
you know how they do the top one he's
not in the top one i mean this guy is a
brilliant
and the great thing about him you don't
hear from him in between he doesn't like
to be
under the radar he doesn't do anything
so so that's that part and then on top
of that
we had a couple other stories we had 60
minutes which is the 60 minutes the
interview that uh
yep uh trump did with leslie with leslie
stahl and then
they did it with uh biden i think even
pence and trump and she was upset at
penn state and she says
she's never interviewed biden there was
confusion there on the president's part
she has personally never interviewed
biden
60 minutes has 60 minutes has
interviewed him but not leslie
and i mean after listening to 30 minutes
that was like two people attacking each
other so he was attacking her as a
person on the air anyway she's always
uncomfortable well but
did you see the first time she
interviewed him or no probably when he
became a president like four years ago
yeah
yeah so and in that whole part but the
biggest factor about this is it's
supposed to be launched a sunday
so it would be because pence sat for the
whole interview yeah
so they have they have air they have
plenty to put on the air
you watch the whole thing i watch what
do you think about it because before
anything i can't say it like try
at least say what would it look like
this is the beginning
like you imagine you're an actor you're
in a movie
your girl is recording the scene and
before the movie comes out you publicize
the scene to everybody so
60 minutes is doing the interview
somebody's sitting there recording him
before 60 minutes plays it on sunday he
plays it so everybody tonight cannot say
that he walked out
yeah goes live with it what was your
take when he watched it so i mean
again it wasn't i didn't take away
anything of substance from it
and that is an increasing source of
frustration i think
i don't care who you're talking about
democrats or republicans you're like i
want to learn what they think about
that's substantive instead of just
listening to two people fight
yeah if i want to listen to two people
fight you know i wouldn't put my italian
i mean well yeah i mean i could just go
find a relative
so but i don't i mean i i'd rather hear
policy and i think that's what americans
are
ready for she obviously they both got
hot under the collar do you think
she was she was irritated and he was
here sorry anything do you think it was
smart on him
no i had my second master's is in
journalism so i think he crossed a very
dark line
oh my god in doing that what did he do
wrong i mean you come to his house
you roll cameras he didn't break into
cbs and steal
video tapes he didn't bolt across he
broke with protocol
and that was just they're not going to
not air what happened between the two of
them it's just you're gonna get to see
both of their faces you know what cbs is
doing
backflips right now do you understand
the numbers on sunday night because
sunday night's gonna be people are gonna
want to know what what their version of
what happened is right but
but we're talking about right and wrong
and
what he did was not right yeah but i
mean is it fair to say that
they've also done the same thing to him
with the whole collusion with russia
i mean my my point is had anything of
substance come out of the 37 minutes
but for me it was just it was just a
stunt
he walked out of the interview and he
wanted to set the record straight i
don't think there's anything wrong he
didn't stay for the entire interview
they said sir you've got five minutes
left on air and he said no
and i mean he didn't like you know rip
off his microphone and storm out
but he did
you know if you go to trump's facebook
page i hope you don't need to log on
but he could have just as easily played
that one little segment that showed i
didn't storm off
you know what i think the biggest
motivation for the people the
journalists doing the interviews
they want to impress their peers they're
doing these interviews for the kudos
that they get from their colleagues
and their bosses she could have got some
substantial information and really
answer some questions he never has but
they're so
busy being in attack mode and trying to
impress their peers
don't keep going no you're right it's
about to come it's the next one i think
oh they took it down no that's it okay
no that's it bigger
make it bigger isn't this amazing they
have a go to 30s
go to 36 minutes here's how it ends
raise the volume
okay played 4.7 million views in six
hours that's a very frustrating
that's what he wanted that's what he
wanted he wanted the view
i i didn't want to have this
kind of money of course you did no i
didn't wish well then you brought up a
lot of subjects that well i think
they were inappropriately questions they
were inappropriate
right from the beginning now your first
question was this is
going to be tough questions well and you
set up the interview
your first statement was president don't
you think you should be
accountable your first statement to me
this is going to be tough questions well
i don't mind that but when you set up
the interview you didn't say that
you said oh let's have a lovely
interview and and here's what i do say
you don't ask joe biden i saw your
interview with joe
the interviewer
the interview 60 minutes i see joe biden
giving softball after softball i've seen
all of his interviews
he's never been asked a question that's
hard okay but forget him no but you
start with me
you're a president excuse me leslie you
started with me
your first statement was are you ready
for tough questions
yeah that's no way to talk no way in
time
lastly one second we're we're
uh this is the first warning i think we
have
five minutes until we have the vice
president set them is that about right
well i think we have enough really we
haven't essentially
i think we're ready for that now
here's the thing i i get how frustrating
he could be but if there's anybody
in politics that is definitely not
one that sway you know avoids being
interviewed and doesn't go into heat you
know when sitting down with
this this guy everybody else obama did
it once with
uh uh what do you call it he sat down
once with hannity not hannity
um uh all right remember that one
interview and then you never saw it
again
he'll go on cnn fox msn he'll go
anywhere to do it so
i don't think it's the thing about him
wanted to step away she flipped her
uh request that she had at the beginning
my only thing is i'm sitting there
thinking about look okay
why did he share it so is he sharing it
because he doesn't want anything to be
asked tonight that's going to hurt him
is he trying to
what's what's his motive of sharing this
that's what i'm trying to find out
he's sharing it to give a glimpse of
what the
motivation is with the media and and
just how they try to spin something
and how well why today like why did he
do it today
what what was in here he was worried
about him did not get people
it cannot be verified that was it was
said over because
the hunter biden business came up
probably four or five times in the 35
minutes they spoke
and she kept repeating after herself it
can't be verified
we cannot report on it if it cannot be
corroborated what if trump knew this was
coming out
what if trump knew that corroboration
itself was coming out today what better
timing could there be
on which side on
the actual they could validate these
emails right
and prove them that the ceo of a company
maybe the gentleman who came out and
said
i have i have the physical emails in my
possession
that the post published
and that's what you said before right we
weren't even recording so check this out
i said there's been five big stories
today right we talked about amy
coney barrett this guy george floyd uh
rudy giuliani the 60 minutes and this
guy here's what he says before he even
watches
by the way generation after generation
in the navy this guy
this guy was friends if you haven't seen
this by the way
he may actually be at the debate tonight
trump is trying to bring him to the
debate tonight similar to our last time
he brought bill clinton's uh mistresses
yeah
accusers accusers not mistresses
accusers oh it was
and he's trying to do the same thing
accusing
mistresses
and tony comes out today
tony was a friend of hunter biden and he
drops the bomb
in the first two minutes press play on
this one
is talking to the media right now he's
armed forces since leaving the navy
i've been involved in various successful
businesses both in this country and
abroad
i'm making the statement to set the
record straight about the involvement of
the biden family
vice president biden his brother jim
biden and his son hunter biden
in dealings with the chinese i've heard
joe biden say that he's never discussed
business with hunter that is false i
firsthand knowledge about this because i
directly dealt with the biden family
including joe biden i have also heard
that vice president biden said on
tuesday
that senator ron johnson the chair of
the senate homeland security committee
should be ashamed for suggesting
that biden family sought to profit from
their name well here are the facts i
know
and everything i'm saying is
corroborated by emails whatsapp chats
agreements documents and other evidence
and the american people can judge for
themselves
i brought i guess for record three
phones
the year 2015 through 2018 it's
unbelievable
never been held by anybody else besides
myself
i was told this past sunday by somebody
who's also involved
you're actually asking that question
because they're holding on to something
go back because we have to hear what
there's what this guy's saying
they're holding on to so go back to hear
the key words
go back i think it's like at 40 seconds
let him play again because i think adam
missed it
uh may be very good with finances when
it comes down to selective hearing
he doesn't hear the things that he
doesn't want to hear he showed me three
phones like a drug dealer play it one
more time
go ahead go ahead there's a lot of drug
dealers in my life president
said on tuesday that senator ron johnson
the chair of the senate homeland
security committee
should be ashamed for suggesting that
biden family sought to profit from their
name
but here are the facts i know and
everything i'm saying is cooperated by
emails
whatsapp chats agreements documents and
other evidence
pause okay go back one more time for
nine seconds adam
listen very carefully to what he says
it's proper everything he's saying
play it again family sought to profit
from their name
well here are the facts i know and
everything i'm saying is cooperated by
emails whatsapp chats agreements
documents and other evidence
and the american people can judge for
themselves so i guess he's guilty
because he used the corroboration word
he said corroborated
[Music]
included i have no wish to bury anyone
i've never been political
the few contributions i've made have
been the democrats but what i am
is a patriot and a veteran to protect my
family name
and my business reputation i need to
ensure that the true facts are out there
in late 2015 i was approached by james
gillier whom i had known for many years
about joining him in the deal which he
said would involve the chinese
state-owned enterprise
cfc china energy and what he called one
of the most prominent families in the
united states
i was informed first by gilliard and
then by hunter biden and by rob walker
who was working with the bidens that the
bidens wanted to form a new entity with
cfc
which was to invest in infrastructure
real estate and technology
in the us and around the world and the
entity would initially be capitalized
with 10 million dollars
and then grow to billions of dollars of
investment capital after months of
discussion
i agreed to gillian hunter bind's
request to become ceo
of the entity to be called synohoc sino
representing the chinese side
hawk representing hunter biden's brother
bo's favorite animal
and between february may 2017 we
exchanged numerous emails documents and
whatsapp messages concerning synohop and
its potential business
on may 2nd 2017 the night before joe
biden was to appear at the milken
conference
i was introduced to joe biden by jim
biden and hunter biden at approx
at my approximately hour-long meeting
with joe that night we discussed the
biden's
history the bride's family business
plans with the chinese with which he was
plainly familiar at least at a high
level
after that meeting i had numerous
communications with hunter walker
gillier and jim biden
regarding the allocation of the equity
ownership of sinawalk on may 13 2017
i received an email concerning
allocation of equity which says 10
percent
held by h for the big guy in that email
there's no question that h stands for
hunter
big guy for his father joe biden
and jim for jim biden in fact hunter
often referred to his father as the big
guy or my chairman
on numerous occasions it was made clear
to me that joe biden's involvement was
not to be mentioned in writing but only
face to face
in fact i was advised by gillian walker
that hunter and jim biden were paranoid
about keeping joe biden's involvement
secrets how bad is this
i also had a disagreement with hunter
about the funds cfc was contributing to
scientific
movie you couldn't get 5 million of
those funds to go to himself and his
family
so he wanted the funds wired directly to
an entity affiliated with him
i objected because
father that cfc was really investing in
the biden family
that he held a trump card and that he
was the one putting his family legacy on
the line
he also said to me on may 17 2017
that cfc wanted to be my partner to be
partnered with the bisons
during these negotiations i repeated to
hunter and others that sanoho could not
be
hunter's personal piggy bank and i
demanded that proper corporate
governance
procedures be implemented for capital
distributions hunter became very upset
with me
csc through july 2017 was assuring me
the funds would be transferred to
cynohawk
but they were never sent to our company
instead i found out
from senator johnson's september report
that the five million dollars was sent
in august 2017
to entities affiliated with hunter
tomorrow
i will be meeting with the senate
committee members concerning this matter
and i will be providing to the fbi the
devices which contain
the evidence cooperating what i have
said so i will not be taking any
questions at this time
did you hear the end of it where you
said that they they moved the money to
hunter they they kicked him out of the
deal
so he's pissed yes that's unbelievable
what do you think about this adam adam
tell us what do you think about this
i mean i think joe biden just dropped
out of the race right you just drop out
what do you i know you're emotionally
pissed off but what do you think about
this okay some dude shows up the day
before election i've never heard of this
guy and all of a sudden i'm supposed to
be like
defending this or that the other how
pissed would you be if you got screwed
over in a deal like what are his
what's his reasonings
let me ask you guys let me ask a
different way here's a different
question for you
so when the dossier came out everybody's
famous question was what
what if this is true what should they do
to trump right
what if this is true
yeah there's going to be legal ram
affirmations what if this is true
there's going to be legal ramifications
which means what what what if freaking
knows i just heard of joe bubba
liske for like this a minute and a half
we watched him
no clue they've been talking about
hunter biden for
years now and they've nothing stuck
biden's winning in the polls still
despite joe
hunter biden's salacious activity
is this going to be enough to put him
over the top we'll see they should bring
this up i'm not asking i'm not asking if
it is anything to put him over the top
does it do anything for you as a voter
what like there's some dude like
speaking for a minute
he doesn't do anything zero for me
really if they actually approved
this guy he's the ceo of a company
if everything can be proven if
everything can be proven
that these talks have been had and that
is the agreement
where are you at you where are you at
position wise
some dude yeah making a speech yeah does
nothing for me
if actually legal ramifications happen
yeah
then yeah how many times did you bring
up russia with trump
did i yeah we can go on the entire
podcast run it back every single
time zero yeah when you start at the
bottom of course it was because it was
done but prior to that
what did you think when you saw the
russia thing with trump trump's up to
some shady stuff with russia you thought
about that
why you jumped to conclusion that was
never the case back it was all over the
tv
wait a minute this is on tv so you
believe that you don't believe this this
is on tv for a minute and a half
but you know what here's what i'm a
trump fan now because
it's not about what you're trying to say
it's not about being a trump fan how
many people hate trump
on the republican side yeah ted cruz
talks [ __ ] about him okay
lindsey graham talks [ __ ] about him um
jeb bush talks [ __ ] about him yeah
every single one of these guys talk [ __ ]
about him and what did you say
well of course they lost to him he
slaughtered them why would he not be
spiteful against this
this is not so this dude got screwed
over by 100 deals
why would he not let me just know it's a
whole different story because you don't
put yourself out and make yourself
the biggest name in the country now
right before the election his life's in
danger
literally you don't do something upside
down because he has so much integrity
because he said he's a patriot
yes oh this guy served what is this guy
got integrity he's a patriot
what would he be talking about
here's what i said on the podcast last
week that they laughed at me deep down i
don't think biden wants to win this
election i don't think he wants to be
president
he knows everything that's in his
background it's a house of cards
it's going to come crumbling down no one
isn't it's not
stupid not to win the presidency
he's raised a billion and a half dollars
he's done every debate he's done
everything
okay for the last week for him not to
want to win the presidency
this just proves that people who are
going to vote for trump are going to
vote for trump and people who are going
to vote for biden are going to vote for
budget
great point and that's that i mean i
don't think
why can't you look at this as a
psychological situation
what's wrong with someone not wanting to
do something that's all i'm saying and i
think
in his heart he would prefer not to know
what does it do for you
i'm going to say this much if if he
happened to have heard
leslie stahl because again two things
happened the same day
i don't think coincidence exists in this
world ever anywhere
if on the same day she's saying there is
no corroboration
over and over and over again maybe he's
throwing up his hands and saying
yes there is crosstalk he could have
done it that quickly i think this had
been planned before
he released this this was
everything's timing right now
if you're asking why did it come out
today it's a hundred percent part of
trump's
strategy it's 100 strategic if you think
why sasha cohen's like the story has
really become big today and the video is
being released when people are watching
it
it's because giuliani was going after
you know hunter stuff and so now they
have to undermine giuliani and they're
hanging on to to embarrass him
and it was easy to do if if anybody's
guys for the last
two months we've all been saying the
same thing october is going to be the
dirtiest
ugliest scariest month of the year it is
nobody's surprise
can you imagine halloween i'm not when i
saw the giuliani thing i'm sitting there
saying
you know by the way he went on howard
stern i don't know if you saw when he
was on howard and
they asked him about this on howard
stern they said so what do you think
about this
and and you know well you know he was
trying to get me but i told him i knew
what they were trying to do
because i've seen that guy before that
stuff may have worked before but it
doesn't work today
and i knew what they were doing then the
girl who's the girl on howard stern
that's been with him for a while what's
her name
so she says well is there anything you
want to tell us that may come out later
on
you know what he said uh uh
you know i don't remember anything first
of all of course you remember as
israel this is rude he's better so you
know when this comes out it's going to
look very very awkward
uh when this thing comes out but for me
when i see something like this
and you show me proof of communication
this is bad news
when when in when the emails of hillary
were taken out
that was bad news okay that's terrible
news because you know
if if they were able to see the emails
you would it's proof you're going to sit
there and say
like wikileaks remember how much of a
role that guy played in the election
last time assange julian assange when
new things would come up because it's
proof
it's email it's written if he can prove
it
this is going to be theory the fbi is
sitting on this laptop
why are they why are they sitting on the
laptop why are they so
if he's going up in front of the senate
tomorrow with his corroborating evidence
then
the senate can say to the fbi why are
you sitting on this laptop
so i mean again we
we as the american people don't know why
the fbi is dragging their feet on this
we should know let me ask you we should
know regardless of who it's about
if it's a matter of national security
but adam if you if you don't mind pat
adam look bro here's the reality behind
these anybody that goes publicly
pro-trump or anti-biden gets ruined
is that simple so it's not just from joe
blow jumping on the tv
risky his entire reputation and his
whole family you go pro trump
and anti-biden publicly you're ruined
because the media will ruin you and that
man's face
will be played back or said or he lied
or he's lying i don't know how many
times
like there's a there's an element to
going pro-trump
and anti-biden right now in this day and
age
today uh whatever eight o'clock or 7 50
texas time bro it's it's it's damn near
social suicide he's got something in
common he's got something in common with
trump he and trump both gave to a bunch
of democrats well you're right so
they said that 100 but the difference
between him
is trump gave to democrat and republican
trump gave to both sides he only gave to
them
only big difference yeah so so i mean so
is it really just some joe blow on there
saying i have three phones and look at
[Music]
this